bonjour à vous jean marc sylvestre alors
est ce que c'est un discours à la
hauteur des attentes des français sur le
plan économique il ya écoutez je ne sais
pas s'il est à la dimension des attentes
des français
je pense que les françaises sont quand
même restés dans une dans une grande
incertitude et dans un grand grand flou
et notamment les chefs d'entreprise mais
je veux dire que pour le gouvernement
dati passionnel est horriblement
compliqué ils avaient le choix entre
deux options pour caricaturer la
première option où il sauvé des vies
ou alors il sauvé l'économie et c'est un
débat qui a existé au plus haut niveau
de l'état d'aller en prenant toute une
journée nous journée de lundi le
confinement
on sait servait sert à protéger les
populations
mais le confinement abouti aussi à
asphyxier la que l'économie on met
l'économie en coma artificiel en quelque
sorte puisque rien ne fonctionne donc le
déconfinement rapide aurait permis sans
doute de faire repartir le mal le marché
économique c'était entre ces deux
options dit fallait qu'il fallait
choisir on a choisi évidemment un
compromis une ligne de crête comme dit
edouard philippe priorité absolue à la
santé mais mise en route progressives et
conditionnelles de l'économie et c'est
tellement progressif et bien qu'on est
absolument un certain que ça pourra se
faire le rose mais dans la mesure où
cette ed confinement est conditionnée
évidemment par les résultats sur la
lutte contre la pandémie
alors c'est vrai qu'on a sorti le
premier ministre un petit peu fébrile
justement sur ce choix comme que vous
décriviez à l'instant sauver des vies ou
sauver l'économie
c'était un discours quand même anxiogène
un discours de vérité selon vous à juste
titre il était effectivement un peu
anxiogène parce qu'il ne donne pas un
certain nombre de précisions vous savez
les gens nous avons tous besoin un peu
de de certitude de savoir où nous allons
or là on a on a un agenda qui est assez
flou sur les procédures de déconfinement
puisque on a vu que le 11 mai on va
commencer on devrait commencer à des
confiné mais de façon très progressive
et très conditionnel les écoles des
transports publics la mise en place
d'aidés des masques etc
le 2 juin on regardera ce qu'on pourra
faire du côté des hôtels restaurants
peut-être des grands magasins aussi des
grands centres commerciaux
et ça c'est très important parce que
c'est toute l'activité touristique et il
y à une pression assez forte du monde du
tourisme aujourd'hui pour pouvoir
commencer à retravailler ouvrir des
plages par exemple il piaffe
d'impatience
or le tourisme c'est une c'est une
activité importante dans l'économie
française ça représente énormément
d'emplois hors embauches le tiers avec
l'activité des services du pipe et si on
rate l'actuel la saison touristique
évidemment l'année sera un peu ce sera
catastrophique corps pour pour
l'ensemble du pays donc
donc on est très vigilant là dessus mais
on n'a pas beaucoup de de certitude
parce que le tourisme c'est aussi une
occasion d'accélérer la mobilité les
gens on va passer du nord au sud de
l'est à l'ouest et donc en mots avec
cette mobilité baa peu accéléré
finalement la mobilité d'une mobilité la
circulation du virus et donc provoquer
cette fameuse deuxième vague que l'on
appréhende autant et puis ça n'est qu'en
septembre on essaiera de se remettre
dans une vie normale notamment avec
toutes les manifestations de foule non
le marché la situation économique est
elle est arrêtée et elle était en coma
artificiel je vous le disais avec un
chômage partiel très important ça coûte
très cher à aller pas ça coûte
énormément le chômage partiel jusqu'en
juin les aides les soutient les plans
garantit aux entreprises on a assez peu
d'informations sur ce qui sera mis en
place pour relancer la machine là on l'a
mais on
soutien aux finances le coma mais
ensuite il va falloir bien sûr la
relancer progressivement et sur ce point
là on a assez peu d'informations
on sait que l'état va soutenir les
entreprises phares du pays mais
s'agissant des indépendants des petites
et moyennes entreprises
là le soutien justement de l'état peut
mieux faire ou pas le l'état pourrait un
peu mieux faire avec la collaboration
des fédérations professionnelles
c'est vrai que les petites et moyennes
entreprises sont prises en étau elles
n'ont plus de chiffre d'affaires d'à
côté 1 les petits commerces les hôtels
les restaurants premiers points 2e point
elles sont obligées d'imaginer ce qui va
se passer dans l'avenir
mettez vous à la place d'un restaurateur
qui dont le modèle économique est fondé
par exemple sur 80 couverts par par jour
si demain il doit ne sert de dire que 40
couverts par ce que il se doit appliquer
la distanciation sociale dans son
restaurant et bien il n'y ni fonctionne
par donc est obligé de mettre la clé
sous la porte donc il a une énorme
inquiétude là dessus avec derrière tout
ça des licenciements vraisemblablement
et puis d'autre part cela petites et
moyennes entreprises avec moins c'est
aussi parce que parfois et bien ses
clients ne le payent pas ne l'ont pas
payé et parfois c'est parfois la grande
entreprise aussi qui n'a pas forcément
payé à temps avec des délais de paiement
un peu rallongé ton qui sont
effectivement dans une difficulté alors
pour l'instant c'est d'entreprise à sion
fortement aidés par des prêts garantis
par l'état et je crois que l' état le
système bancaire fait le job mais c'est
relativement longs les procédures
administratives sont relativement long
et on voit toujours que dans ce pays on
a une administration affreusement
lourdes et qui a du mal d'eau ce
sentiment de prendre des décisions mais
qui ne sont pas forcément appliqué il
doit donc dans l'immédiat
merci beaucoup jean marc sylvestre pour
nous avoir livré votre analyse ce matin
merci à vous